[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello,
and we are live.
And almost on time.
We had to catch the end
of the Giants game.
COLT McANLIS: Congratulations
to the Giants.
Bravo, gentlemen.
TODD KERPELMAN: Nice work.
COLT McANLIS: Nice beard.
I'm jealous.
TODD KERPELMAN: So welcome to
Google Games Chat, episode
number six.
I am Todd Kerpelman,
your moderator and
host and cat herder.
WOLFF DOBSON: The host
with the most.
TODD KERPELMAN: To my left
is Wolff Dobson.
Doctor Wolff Dobson.
WOLFF DOBSON: Thank you.
TODD KERPELMAN: To my immediate
right we have Colt
McAnlis, and to his right
we have John McCutchan.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Hello.
TODD KERPELMAN: So how are
you guys doing today?
COLT McANLIS: We are doing
very Canadian today.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: It's
very Canadian out.
COLT McANLIS: It is
a little Canadian.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's a little
Canadian, it's kind of
fall-ish weather.
COLT McANLIS: It's good
caffeination weather.
It's good Seattle weather.
Stay inside, play some video
games, drink some caffeine.
It's good weather to
watch this show.
WOLFF DOBSON: I was listening
to some Maple Leaf Rag, you
know, that kind of thing.
COLT McANLIS: There you go.
I don't know if that's Canadian,
but close enough.
WOLFF DOBSON: It does have
maple leaves in it.
What do you want?
TODD KERPELMAN: So
let's jump in.
We're going to jump right into
our first tech demo, I guess
first and only tech demo,
because Wolff couldn't get his
act together.
And that's going to be--
WOLFF DOBSON: I love you, man.
No, really.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm kidding.
He really couldn't.
He was drunk!
COLT McANLIS: He still is.
WOLFF DOBSON: Thank you.
Well, anyway, we launched
version 1.3 of the Hangouts
API this morning.
TODD KERPELMAN: Actually, all
right, you know what, wait.
We're not going to
jump into techno.
Tell me about--
what's in version 1.3?
WOLFF DOBSON: It's actually
a very small update.
It's--
COLT McANLIS: It just
includes beer.
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
We renamed one of the methods
to be more accurate.
But the fun thing that you can
do is if you're working on
Effects, you can unmirror
your local stream.
So normally when you're like--
especially if you're going
with text effects, you see it
backwards, because you're
looking at yourself
in a mirror.
So we've made it so there's
an API method to
flip it back and forth.
I assume with unmirroring, you
finally have vampires able to
see themselves in
their Hangout.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's true,
because the mirror rule
doesn't apply to Hangouts.
They can finally
see themselves.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, that's
interesting.
If you have vampires, and you
put them in Hangouts, do they
see themselves because it's a
camera and not actually a--
COLT McANLIS: Wait, are
we talking about
a traditional vampire?
WOLFF DOBSON: --but when you
turn on video mirroring, do
they disappear?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Yes.
COLT McANLIS: So we're in
a different state now.
We're in a different
state now.
The traditional vampire that
bursts into flames in the sun
is no longer our standard
quota for
society-accepted vampires.
WOLFF DOBSON: Are you talking
about sparkly vampires?
COLT McANLIS: I'm not
specifying anything.
I'm just saying we have
to update our persona.
The internet didn't exist back
when, you know, van Helsing
was around.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's true.
Mirrors were really
the only way.
There weren't cameras,
there weren't-- yeah.
Interesting.
WOLFF DOBSON: So do vampires
upload themselves to YouTube
and look at themselves?
They don't actually
see themselves--
TODD KERPELMAN: That's the
only way they can.
You know, we really should save
this discussion for two
weeks from now, when we're like
in our Halloween episode
or something.
But so does it actually unmirror
the entire display,
or just the Effects layer?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, it unmirrors
the entire stream, so that you
can see yourself.
TODD KERPELMAN: So you get
that weird experience of
seeing yourself way other people
see you, which is,
like, totally unsettling.
WOLFF DOBSON: Does my hair
part on that side?
Whoa.
And your eyes don't look like
they're in the right position.
That's probably true for
me all the time.
COLT McANLIS: I like how you
complained about your hair.
That's, uh, that's cute.
That's cute, by the way.
TODD KERPELMAN: I host
a demo today, right?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Hold on,
let's stay on hair.
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's talk
more about hair.
COLT McANLIS: First World
hair problems.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So let's move on to the demo.
So John, what do you
have for us today?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: So today I'm
going to show an update to the
NaCl acceleration module that
if you happened to catch
episode two or three--
was it three?
TODD KERPELMAN: It
was like three.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Three.
If you caught it live, which
it never made it up to
YouTube, you would have seen a
prerecorded sample of this.
But I'm going to show a live
demo of this today.
So what we're looking at here is
the Bullet physics library
is running in the background
without any display, and I'm
communicating with it
through JavaScript.
So I have a JavaScript API to
Bullet and I'm drawing and
doing everything in JavaScript,
which is pretty sweet.
I can even grab a block and pick
it up and move it around
and smash over this
Jenga pile.
The picking of the objects is
done in JavaScript and the
actual physical simulation
is done in C.
It's ridiculously fast.
Let me see if I can knock
over this table.
There we go.
So the whole simulation is
taking right now about between
one and two milliseconds to
simulate over 100 objects,
which is just amazing.
But you get to write your
application in JavaScript.
I'm just using 3.js to
do all the drawing.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is very cool.
I think we used this analogy
last time, but it's like in
the old days when the PC
developers, they would write
all their high-level stuff in C
and then they would go into
Assembly for all of the really
heavy lifting kinds of things.
This is sort of that same idea
taken up one level higher,
where now you get to--
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Yeah, exactly.
So now you have your low-level
stuff, which in this case is a
mix of C and Assembly, and you
write all of your high-level
stuff in JavaScript.
But this demo is available in
the Chrome Web Store, and
there's actually a mode in it
where you can describe the
shapes and the initial state of
the scene in a JSON file,
and load it up in the
application and
watch it play out.
COLT McANLIS: What's really cool
about this, what I like
about seeing this demo is, we
talk a lot-- or rather there's
a lot of tension in the Web
community right now about what
language should be
used on the Web.
You've kind of got different
herds of people all saying
that A is right and--
WOLFF DOBSON: You're
calling them sheep?
Is that what you're saying?
COLT McANLIS: There's lots
of different words.
So what happens is, this is
really one of the first times
that we've come to the table
and said, hey, what happens
when we actually hit
the magic spot?
That it's not just one language,
but we find out how
to meld the right things of
each language together.
This is still using JavaScript
to render and to manage the
scene, but the high
computational cost, the
processing cost, is actually
all being run in
Native Client in C code.
So we actually have the
ability to have a
conversation, I believe, which
is that maybe one language
isn't meant to rule them all.
Maybe we can actually
take, from each
language, the best parts.
And use that to make the Web a
better place, especially when
you get to see great
stuff like this.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, what
about debugging all
these things, though?
I mean, whenever you--
I can remember tales of working
in Lua, because you
could compile it and have it run
on a console, and then you
discover you're sitting there,
like, writing a Lua debugger
inside your regular
C debugger.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Well, so the
nice thing is that Chrome
ships with a JavaScript
debugger.
WOLFF DOBSON: That
is what I was--
this is the thing.
Like, the reason why you write
in JavaScript is because then
you get Chrome's awesome
debugger.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Yeah, and you
get the profiler, and the
memory profiler.
WOLFF DOBSON: You just get all
these things that you need
that makes it easy to develop.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Yep.
And the way that the
acceleration models are meant
to work is, though, somewhat
off-the-shelf.
It's essentially middleware.
So you get a straightforward
JavaScript API, like--
in the JavaScript code it's
like, Add Event Listeners,
Seen Update, and call this
JavaScript function.
And it takes the transforms
that Bullet computed and
applies them to all the
objects in the scene.
COLT McANLIS: Which is
really cool, right?
Especially when we get to
a situation where we--
because everyone pretty
much includes jQuery.
It'd be great if instead of
including jQuery we just
started including
physics modules.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: That's exactly
what's happening here.
WOLFF DOBSON: #include
awesome.
COLT McANLIS: Which is really
kind of nice for the future of
the Web, and when you think
about Web gaming and where
this can take it.
You know, HTML5 offers this
great ability to have very
flexible gameplay, but again may
not give you some of the
performance in the
areas you need.
And that's where these
NaCl acceleration
modules fit right in.
TODD KERPELMAN: Very cool.
So now is--
I don't know much about the
Bullet module besides the fact
that we've been using it.
Has that been written
in-house?
Is that written external?
Where'd that come from?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: So Bullet is an
open-source physics library.
You can find it on
Google Code.
And what I did was I
wrote two things.
One, I wrote a general-purpose
library that allows you to
glue C to JavaScript by
way of postMessage.
And then I wrote a Bullet
module for that, so that
implements a few function calls
that you want to send
from JavaScript into
the C land.
Like, I figure out what object
is under the mouse cursor in
JavaScript, and then I send over
a message to C that says,
OK, pick this object up now,
and start holding it.
And then when I'm ready to drop
it, I send a message to C
that says, OK, drop this now.
So what you're seeing is
actually a very tight coupling
of back-and-forth chatter
between JavaScript and C, and
it works really well.
WOLFF DOBSON: How many--
what's the limit on messages
that you can
send to the NaCl module?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I did a bunch of
benchmarks, and I actually
have a talk that's available,
that came out today on GDL.
WOLFF DOBSON: Are you saying
I didn't do my homework?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Absolutely.
COLT McANLIS: We
sent it around.
You didn't even Share
it on G+.
Where's the gamedev bro-love?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: All right.
But quickly, you can send about
400 megabytes per second
of data, round trip, from JS
to C. And the latency for
small messages is about
100 microseconds.
COLT McANLIS: So what this
effectively means is, with
things like NaCl acceleration
modules, you can actually put
a video decoder in Native
Client, and actually ship all
the data over to JavaScript.
WOLFF DOBSON: I was going
to say, it sounds like
programming on the PS2, where
you're streaming your textures
in as you're playing.
Which is neat, because you can
actually construct the
textures out of getUserMedia
or something like that, and
then map them onto it.
COLT McANLIS: Especially
think of it this way.
With all the advances we've seen
with archive compression
modules, like LZHAM and 7Zip and
stuff like that, and with
the adoption of compressed
texture formats into WebGL,
you can now actually store your
stuff in hyper-compressed
data, decompress it using Native
Client and C++ and
still stream over to WebGL
and use it there.
So really, really exciting.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: So to put that
400 megabytes per second into
perspective, you can do 1024 by
1024, 60 frames per second
of RGBA frames and only
use 200 of it.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're like, "It's
an entire Final Fantasy
game per second."
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Yes.
Yeah.
So the great thing about the
Bullet acceleration model is
that the actual output that
you send every frame is 64
bytes per body being
simulated.
But the amount of memory being
touched in the computation
that's going on inside the
C land is massive.
And then you just send over
64 bytes per body.
And that's all you have to
send over to JavaScript.
COLT McANLIS: This
is good stuff.
Check it out.
It's on the Chrome Web
Store, definitely go
take a look at it.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Yeah, there's
a talk, and I have a blog
post, and this application.
You can go and install this in
the Chrome Web Store and make
your own domino scene and then
just see it simulate.
TODD KERPELMAN: I hope people do
that, because-- well, one,
I love dominoes, but two,
I love physics games.
The more physics games are
out there, the better.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Jenga.
Jen-jen-jenga.
WOLFF DOBSON: Just the Stair
Dismount is my favorite.
Just throwing the poor guy down
the stairs, endlessly.
You just don't get tired of
it, this is the thing.
I just thought of that now, and
I was like, ah, I gotta go
install that afterwards.
TODD KERPELMAN: About two
companies ago, I had this
prototype for a game that I
was working on that was
nothing more than shooting a guy
out of a cannon and just
watching him hit all these
random obstacles in the world.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Wasn't that Pain
for the Playstation 3?
TODD KERPELMAN: No,
it was not.
This was a 2D kind of thing.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: But
that's essentially
the same game, right?
Like that, you just set up your
slingshot and you shoot
the guy into the world
and you see how much
damage you can do.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
more or less.
WOLFF DOBSON: That was built
into one of those racing
games, where they figured out--
they made it so they had
a rag doll guy in the car and
then when he crashed, it would
basically just eject him.
He would just fall out.
And then they realized that was
so much fun, they added
this entire sub-game where all
you did was crash the car.
And they had targets for the
body, so you had to hit at the
right angle and the right
speed to launch the
guy into the thing.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
You can't ever really
get tired of
watching rag doll physics.
All right, so with that,
let's move into our
Five for Five topic.
You know what we need is like,
we need a cool little graphic
intro where we kind of talk
about introducing this.
WOLFF DOBSON: Like, zeeeeow!
COLT McANLIS: Five for Five!
WOLFF DOBSON: Five for Five!
TODD KERPELMAN: Can we-- let
me ask our producer.
Can we get on that?
WOLFF DOBSON: Jimmy?
TODD KERPELMAN: Jimmy says yes,
he's going to build it
for next time.
That would be great.
COLT McANLIS: Perfect time for
the Halloween episode.
WOLFF DOBSON: [INAUDIBLE],
you're Jimmy.
COLT McANLIS: All statements
by Wolff Dobson are his own
opinion, and not that of any
organization that he may be
affiliated with at any time.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
so I've got five topics--
WOLFF DOBSON: All of my
opinions are cult.
TODD KERPELMAN: And we're going
to talk for five minutes
and 30 seconds, because we may
need a little more time.
And then when the
timer buzzes--
COLT McANLIS: What are
we talking about?
TODD KERPELMAN: I don't know.
COLT McANLIS: Ready, go!
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
there's the first question.
There was an article on Kotaku,
I think last week,
that basically argued that
quick saves have ruined
tension in games.
There's never any
point where--
WOLFF DOBSON: "Games
are dead!"
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, games are
dead, or at least tension
in games are dead, because if
you can quick save every few
minutes or every few seconds or
every couple of steps, that
tension is gone.
Do we agree?
Do we think that we need to
remove quick saves to bring
tension back into games?
WOLFF DOBSON: You know
what we should do?
It should punch you in the
stomach every time
you die in a game.
That's what we should
do to people.
No, for me it's all
about, does this
game respect my time.
I gave up on Grand Theft Auto
San Andreas near the end,
because they had a mission where
you sat through a long
cutscene, and then you
parachuted down to a place,
and then you had to kill all
the guys-- this unskippable
thing where you had to kill all
the guys on the helipad,
then you had to go from the
helipad down to the thing.
And then finally you get
to the car racing part.
And the car racing part was
really slow, clumsy, with
like, tires made out of
petroleum jelly, so you're
skidding all over the place
trying to chase this guy.
Each try took like 11 minutes.
And the problem with that is
that I wasn't getting better
at driving while I was
practicing that whole sequence.
I was doing the thing that I
already mastered, which is
clearing the house full of
guys, shooting guns and
parachuting, which
wasn't very hard.
And the part that I needed
practice on was the part that
I couldn't practice, and instead
had to pay 11 minutes
every time I wanted to see it.
And that was the end
of the game for me.
When you look at a game like
VVVVVV, it's brutally hard,
but it lets you keep practicing
the part you need
to practice, over and
over and over again.
Super Meat Boy, and
things like that.
Those games are incredibly
tense.
They're just letting
you focus on the
parts that are important.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Yeah.
Well, I've gotta bring up Dark
Souls and Demon Souls, which
are exactly what you described,
and I think that's
why a lot of people love them.
That's certainly why
I was really
attracted to those games.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, what skill
are you practicing when you're
playing Dark Souls?
What are you mastering when
you're mastering Dark Souls.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: You're
mastering the
combat system, you're--
WOLFF DOBSON: But you're
not mastering,
like, a physical thing.
You're mastering the sort of
long-term economics of
managing your party.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Well, there's
no party in the game.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, whatever.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I think
what you're
mastering, one, is the combat.
So when you're--
it's a little bit more
like fencing, though.
So it's a little bit more like
OK, I'm just going to get one
hit in, and then I'm going to
back off and be patient for a
beat or two, and then come
back in for it again.
But what makes the game
so interesting
is that death matters.
And it's funny that we're
talking about quick saving,
because Dark Souls
always saves.
It's saving constantly.
Every minute the game saves.
And you can't go back to a
previous version of the save,
but it's always being written.
So there's a couple times where
I made a really bad
mistake and I actually
ran across a room and
unplugged the PS3.
COLT McANLIS: [LAUGHTER]
JOHN McCUTCHAN: So
that it wouldn't
write to the save file.
So this is like, the other
way of quick saving.
Forced quick saves adds
a lot of tension.
WOLFF DOBSON: This is like when
I used to hack games and
change bits inside it so
it would get easier.
It was like, what I'm actually
learning is how to hack the
games, and not--
TODD KERPELMAN: I mean,
that's basically
saying no quick saves.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Well,
it's always saving.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's like the
Iron Man mode in the new XCOM
game, where, yeah, there's--
it's quick saving without
reloading.
WOLFF DOBSON: See, I still think
this comes down to what
you're mastering, though.
Because when you're playing Dark
Souls, what you're doing
is getting good at managing this
long sequence of actions
that you have to do.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: But that's
exactly what's going on with
GTA, right?
It is, like, to get from one
point, kind of checkpoint in
Dark Souls to the next, it's
this long sequence of
different action moments.
WOLFF DOBSON: But are
they really--
are they completely orthogonal
to each other?
Or are they all related.
So that if you got good at the
first half, you'd be better at
the second half.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: It's
all combat.
WOLFF DOBSON: So it's all the
same skill that you're
practicing.
I mean, different guys, but
you're still ultimately
getting your pattern down.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: You are
mastering your character and
their abilities.
WOLFF DOBSON: But this was
my complaint about GTA.
It was that you aren't
mastering the--
TODD KERPELMAN: You just needed
checkpoints after the
parachuting part, after the
clearing-out-the-guys part.
WOLFF DOBSON: I want the thing
that I'm practicing to be the
thing that I'm trying
to overcome, not--
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I've had that
same experience in games,
where there's a sequence of five
totally separate moments,
and I can do four of them, and
the fifth one I just suck at.
And you just do it again
and again and again.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, and there's
no way to isolate
that, and like, practice that
muscle until you've got it
just right.
And I mean, I think that article
comes down to, yeah,
terribly implemented save
systems are really
frustrating, or terribly
designed save systems are
frustrating.
MALE SPEAKER: So our YouTubes
have some good feedback.
Two pieces.
One person says they hated it
in Quake that if you did a
quick save at the wrong time
you'd forever reload and die.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, again,
poorly implemented save.
MALE SPEAKER: Someone else
says, quick save was
practically a must-have feature
in the 90s, and if you
didn't have it, you
were screwed.
COLT McANLIS: See, so now I'm
going to agree with this.
So here's my thought, is that
quick save has nothing to do
with the tension of the game.
TODD KERPELMAN: By the way,
thank you, audience, for
contributing.
That's awesome.
Yaay!
COLT McANLIS: Thank you.
So, like, Half-Life 2,
you could quick save
wherever you want.
But that was still a
really tense game.
And to go back to your
point, yes, you are
trying to master something.
But it allowed you to say,
I will master x at
a specific y time.
So really the only time it
removes tension is if you're
someone who's obviously
manipulating that to an extreme.
And that person's probably not
caring about tension of the
environment anyway.
They're trying to optimize--
they're trying to min-max
the system.
I got the last word in.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, you
got the last word in.
Actually, I think that's
probably a good point to move
on to our next question.
WOLFF DOBSON: Design
good save points.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: But
I totally agree.
Half-Life 2 was a very
tense game for me,
even with quick save.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, you
didn't abuse it.
COLT McANLIS: The general
thing is, hyperbolic
statements like "quick saves do
x," I think that's wrong.
I think you have to take a look
at the user and how the
user's experiencing
your content.
If the user is going to
manipulate something, that's
how they're trying to experience
your content.
We all can agree that the
original Everquest resulted in
horrible death penalties.
When you got to level 42 and
you died, you lost a half a
bar of experience, which took
you two days to get back.
One of the successful things
that modern MMOs do to combat
that is when you die, you
don't lose experience.
You can kind of see that as a
quick save, but there's still
tension, there's still something
on the line.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're still
frustrated when you lose.
And you're knocked out
of the raid, which is
a bad enough penalty.
They don't need to also lop
off three days of effort.
COLT McANLIS: Yeah, I'm just
saying that hyperbolic
statements like what was made
in the article are trying to
address the wrong thing.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Are they
trying to get clicks?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, the
word linkbait was
going off in my head.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: That
never happens.
WOLFF DOBSON: We totally
fell for it.
TODD KERPELMAN: They got,
like, four extra clicks.
WOLFF DOBSON: Todd's
like, gyawww.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So, HTML5.
I feel like for a long time
game developers have been
saying, this is going to be the
future of Web games, it's
the future, it's the future.
I feel like we're--
from a few years ago, we're now
in the future, and it's
still kind of off
in the future.
WOLFF DOBSON: Where are
the flying cars?
Where are the robot butlers?
What's going on?
TODD KERPELMAN: Right.
We're getting closer to the
self-driving cars, I don't
know about the flying one.
But I still feel like, if I look
at the most popular games
on the Web, if I go to
Kongregate and see what's
driving a lot of the online
games right now, it's still
primarily Flash.
Some Unity, and you know,
HTML5 is there.
But it hasn't becomes the
dominant force yet, in games
in the browser.
Why not?
I'm asking you.
COLT McANLIS: That's
fine, that's fine.
So I think you bring up a very
good point about sort of,
where is the evolution
of HTML5.
And I want to approach
this from a long
view perspective first.
So first off, when HTML5 was
first announced and what it
was doing and what it was
capable of, you have to
remember that the browser share
that actually supported
HTML5 was actually pretty low.
And game developers of that time
were very much concerned
about reach.
I mean, we're talking about late
2008, early 2009, when
the big thing to do was to write
a Flash game and put it
on a social network.
So you were more concerned
with daily active users
clicking your pink cow than
you were anything else.
So fast-forward to 2012.
We've now got--
the dominant share of users
can run HTML5 games.
The problem now is
that the focus is
in a different medium.
The focus is in mobile and
what mobile is doing.
We did a great thing for
Google I/O this year.
We actually took some game
developers, or some ex-game
developers who work at Google,
and we made a game.
We said, let's figure out if
this HTML5 thing is actually
worth the hype.
We made a game called Grits,
which is a top-down 2D
shooter, and you could actually
just Google for my
name and the word Grits and
you'll find everything.
But we actually took a look at
it and said, we're ex-game
developers.
Let's approach HTML5 and
figure out if it's
hype or if it's not.
And what we found was this, was
that people approaching
HTML5 development have
two skewed views.
Number one, they think
it's in a vacuum.
They believe that HTML5
development is its own little
island and no one's ever
made games before.
Like, the people we talked to
were completely oblivious to
very good tools, like
TexturePacker or Tiled.
These are staples of 2D
game development.
The people in the HTML5 world,
or even the Web world, just
didn't know.
They're coming from the world
where they're expecting this
IDE that Flash has,
and expecting
something to migrate over.
So that was first an issue, in
sort of educating people that
hey, listen, it's all data.
If you export a 3D model
from Maya, you
can load it in WebGL.
It's just data.
The second problem was that
developers were sort of
approaching the HTML5 concept
from a very different
viewpoint, which was that they
thought it should all be
integrated and all solve
every problem,
everywhere, at every time.
Which kind of is due to the
hyperbolic nature of the
statements.
But what we've really found is
that HTML5 is a Web language.
It was designed for
the internet.
Believe it or not, it wasn't
actually designed for games.
What we've been able to do is,
because HTML5 is so powerful,
we've been able to do
gaming experiences.
Well, this comes to the tier
of like, what the demo John
showed and everything, which is
that HTML5 is great for a
tier of experiences.
When you want to move beyond
that tier, you're going to
quickly run into problems.
And my talk, I talk about
that, I won't go into it
today, but when you hit that
tier you're going to say, hey,
you know what, there's certain
things that we just cannot do.
It's like dealing with limited
hardware right?
You're not going to be able to
render 2.4 million polygons on
your mobile device today.
It just doesn't work.
So it's a tier of
applications.
Once you hit that point, you've
got to move forwards.
So I believe the future of HTML5
is very bright, I'm very
encouraged about it, but I think
the problem has been
messaging, to this point.
It's been very hyperbolic.
It hasn't been very pragmatic
about what game developers
should actually be doing.
So I have I monopolized the
whole five minutes yet?
TODD KERPELMAN: Not yet.
WOLFF DOBSON: So I was going
to say that I came from a
background first
of console game
development, and then Flash.
And when I started writing HTML5
games, a little bit like
what you were talking
about, I felt like--
and, you know, this was
a couple years ago--
I felt a little bit
lobotomized.
Like oh, I don't have all of
these really comfy tools that
I'm used to.
Now I feel a lot more like it's
like LISP, like where I
fire up the game, I open the
console, and I start typing
stuff in the console.
Like, I'm developing much more
like I developed in grad
school, when I was working
on AI, than I was
as a console developer.
Because back when I was working
even on the Dreamcast
and the Wii, you fire up a
run, and then you go--
I used to draw on my whiteboard
a lot, because I'd
wait for two and a half minutes
for it to start, and
then I'd be able to play it.
And with HTML5, I can sit there
and write code in the
command line as I'm going along,
and that's faster than
using the IDEs, because I have
such an interactive experience
when I'm coding.
And I think that's a mode of
coding that people who come
from C backgrounds aren't
as familiar with.
COLT McANLIS: And so I will
point this out, too.
Probably one of the most
important things I think that
Chrome has done, in being
open source, is
the auto-update feature.
Again, when we talk about who
has HTML5 support in the
browser, again, it was very
limited early on.
Now Chrome's got a fantastic
user base.
A lot of the other browser
vendors have realized that the
auto-update feature allows you
to kind of keep on the cutting
edge, and a lot of them have
announced support for
auto-update.
Which means that we're going to
have more HTML5 support in
the future, and that means that
users are all going to
have HTML5 support.
So now it's a better time than
ever to actually come to the
table and write an HTML5 game
that gets good reach and has
good performance.
Now again, here's the
pragmatic statement.
You're still writing on
fragmented hardware.
If you're coming out and you're
actually writing a
WebGL game, your shader may
not run on every device.
So again, it's sort of where
the Web meets hardware.
And we're seeing that a lot,
again, with these mobile
devices, where you've got
technology that's supposed to
be homogeneous but hardware
that's heterogeneous.
And we need to kind of come to
the table and say hey, game
developers have been dealing
with this for a long time.
This is nothing new.
It's just a new language
in a new ecosystem.
WOLFF DOBSON: I also think that
Chrome on Android is a
big step forwards.
COLT McANLIS: Absolutely.
WOLFF DOBSON: Like, making an
HTML5 game and then trying to
run it really slowly on 2009
mobile browsers was like oh,
this is terrible.
Now we get hardware
acceleration, now we get all
these things that you want.
Like a really great JavaScript
compiler, or Runtime.
These are the tools
that I needed.
I need.
I need?
I have.
I have them.
COLT McANLIS: You have, today.
Go use them.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I'm a Flash
developer, I'm a theoretical
Flash developer, and
I'm saying--
WOLFF DOBSON: You're a
theoretical Flash developer!
So, wait, there's so many
ways to parse that.
Are you theoretical as in you
don't actually exist, or--
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's suppose
I'm a Flash developer--
COLT McANLIS: Where's
the comma?
TODD KERPELMAN: --and I'm
saying, all right, I'm going
to get into making a game in
HTML5, what do I need to know?
So my tools are different.
I need to actually go
out and look for--
I can't expect all of them to
be available in my IDE, but
there are some good ones
out there that I
should be looking for.
COLT McANLIS: So first off, I
think you should start at the
fact that even Adobe has
started adopting HTML5.
I think the newer IDEs they
have actually have either
HTML5 support, and if you don't
want to opt in for that
tier of support there, there's
also great HTML5 packages out
there, like EaselJS is a
fantastic one, that will
actually take Flash over to
JavaScript on your behalf.
When you get to that sort of
scenario, though, if you
realize that you don't want to
use the Flash IDE for your
primary editing environment,
then yeah.
You need to go back and you need
to look at how we've been
making video games for
the past 30 years.
I mean, how many games
are actually
built on mobile today?
What tools are they using?
A lot of them are 2D.
Maybe you should research
that data.
Look for it.
I'll tell you, the two main ones
are Tiled, for creating
world maps and everything,
and the other one is
TexturePacker.
TexturePacker is fantastic.
It'll create atlases, it'll
minimize your footprint, it'll
increase your speed.
It's a great thing.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
those two tools.
And start loving the idea
that you can code while
everything's running.
It's sort of awesome.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: There was a
really interesting demo that
someone's put together of that
type of programming working
with C and C++.
It's called Juce, J U
C E, and I watched a
YouTube video of it.
It is very impressive stuff.
I mean, the demo is presenting
like a UI with a button and
things like that, and they
actually clicked in the
running application, made the
button bigger, and you saw the
source code change.
And it's all using LLVM and
Clang, and it's good stuff.
COLT McANLIS: Now, what I'll
say about this, and I know
we're over time, but I think
it's an important point about
Web technologies, is we're
actually starting to see a lot
of people realizing what can
be done in a browser and
trying to bridge it.
Because we have a lot of
developers coming to the
table, especially from the
traditional industry, who have
a C++ code base with 10
million lines of code.
For them to migrate into the
Web, that may not be easy, if
they're trying to take
everything to JavaScript.
So we've seen some good stuff
come forward, like the LLVM
compilers that'll take C++ and
convert it to JavaScript.
We've been seeing Native Client
making some good headway.
We've been seeing Dart doing
great stuff too.
I think the important thing,
again, is to come back and say
let's talk about user
experience, let's talk about
data, and let's talk
about where the
future of the Web is.
Now that we can actually get
to the tip of the iceberg,
we're seeing the performance
start, we're seeing the user
experiences come through.
Where does that lead us.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
moving on to a question that
has absolutely nothing to do
with games, but I thought I'd
ask it anyway.
Which is--
WOLFF DOBSON: Speaking
as a parent.
TODD KERPELMAN: Speaking
So--
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Let me derail
this conversation right now.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
I got two kids.
I'm going to assume that in
15 to 18 years, they're--
WOLFF DOBSON: Theoretical
children.
TODD KERPELMAN: I've got my
theoretical children.
COLT McANLIS: They're
theoretical Flash children.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I
actually have 37
theoretical Flash children.
COLT McANLIS: That's
a lot of work.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: A lot
of theoretical work.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm putting
money away every paycheck to a
college fund, based on the idea
that at some point in the
future I'm going to need to
spend an awful lot of money to
send these kids to college.
At the same time I'm spending,
like, my morning bus ride
watching Stanford classes
on my computer.
And I'm like hey, wait, I'm
getting this for free, I don't
need to pay a quarter of a
million dollars or whatever.
WOLFF DOBSON: Why buy the
cow when you can get
the milk for free?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
So this is my question.
Is the idea of saving for
college kind of weird and
old-fashioned?
WOLFF DOBSON: Are you looking
for an excuse to blow your
kid's college fund?
I'm looking for an excuse to
blow my kid's college fund and
go to Hawaii for a year.
So can I justify this?
WOLFF DOBSON: I think--
so, weirdly, there's
some data on this.
And there's also some--
and, sadly, I'm not going to
be able to footnote it,
because I just read some stuff
on the Web once, and it seemed
really convincing.
COLT McANLIS: On, like,
a totally legit site.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
COLT McANLIS: Seems
legit, bro.
COLT McANLIS: There's
theoretical footnotes.
No, there's some data on this,
and there's also interesting
things where it's like, we have
all these tools available.
Like you can go buy a laptop for
$300, and you're connected
to the Web, and you can do
all these amazing things.
You can watch these
Standford courses.
TODD KERPELMAN: Coursera,
yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: You can
do all these things.
And I think those are going to
be really powerful for certain
kinds of applications.
There's very little evidence
that when you cut people loose
with like, a calculus textbook
and some video recordings of
calculus, that they come
out learning calculus
on the other side.
Programming is a different
thing, because it's such an
interactive--
online programming courses
make tons of sense to me,
because it's like yeah,
this is how we all
learned how to program.
Just sort of keep fiddling
with it until it works.
Calculus doesn't lend itself
to that very much.
It's not that you can't.
It just happens very rarely, as
compared to people teaching
themselves to program,
learning to program.
So some of that is, programming
is a kind of thing
that is easy to teach
yourself.
And calculus or sociology,
possibly not.
The other thing has to do
with-- there's lots of
educational theory on this.
When you're in a room with a
bunch of people who are all
trying to do calculus, you're
all helping each other and
you're all focusing each other
on the same thing.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Hangouts.
WOLFF DOBSON: This
is the thing.
You know, a year ago--
COLT McANLIS: I don't think he
was going that direction, but
I think you just made him
go that direction.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, there's
actually a term for it.
It's called the zone of
proximal development.
Like, when we're all in a room
together, we create a zone.
It's actually a very confusing
paper in Polish, but it's--
I think it's Polish.
Vygotsky is the guy.
COLT McANLIS: Seems legit.
WOLFF DOBSON: That I actually
can footnote.
The zone of proximal development
is a real
educational theory.
COLT McANLIS: Seems legit.
WOLFF DOBSON: But it really is,
like, when people get in a
room together, they teach
you their stuff.
And gaming is like this too.
When you're sitting there trying
to figure out how to
optimize your whatever, your
Street Fighter combos, it
really helps to have somebody
else in the room with you.
And you're all thinking about
it at the same time.
No, give me the controller,
let me try it.
Like, this kind of stuff.
So I think to the degree that
we can create online
communities that create the
zone, so to speak, that's
going to be an interesting
torque on this.
But the other thing is there
was the study that came out
recently that was saying
that if you--
the money you spend on college,
if you're taking out
loans, the amount of money you
make, the extra money that you
make for having a college
degree, does not necessarily
pay back the loans.
Depending on the size of the
loans that you take.
Like, if you borrow completely
to get your college education.
But if your parents are paying
for it, it's an awesome deal.
And part of that is because
you're not paying-- the
interest is very different.
But that's more economics
theory than game theory.
TODD KERPELMAN: What
do you think, John?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I think
you move to Canada.
WOLFF DOBSON: I was about
to say, you're Canadian.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Or any other
country where higher education
is not something that is
equivalent to buying a house.
And then your child's education
fund could be very
small, relatively speaking,
and it'll be all right.
I mean, by the time I
was done with grad
school I had made money.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow,
I cannot say that.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: You get--
I mean, you start to get
paid to do research.
WOLFF DOBSON: I wouldn't call
the stipend I was getting in
grad school--
we called it a pittance.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Sure, and it
was, but it offset the four
years of undergrad.
For me, as a Canadian.
WOLFF DOBSON: Not for me.
But I went to private school,
so it was crazy.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: We don't
really have that.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
do we have three
comments from the others?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Not
as a parent.
MALE SPEAKER: So, Todd!
We have another question
which is on-topic.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh, a
question on-topic.
MALE SPEAKER: The question is,
and this goes to anyone, what
free frameworks would
you recommend?
Now, free, not three.
Free.
WOLFF DOBSON: Frameworks
for HTML5 development?
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
WOLFF DOBSON: EaselJS.
It's part of the--
I think it's CreativeJS?
It's got TweenJS, it's
got all this stuff.
If you know a little Flash, or
even a lot of Flash, you'll
feel very much at
home in Easel.
It's not quite Flash, because
containers can't also be
rendered objects, but it is a
retained mode, 2D, Z-sorted
graphics system.
So you'll get going really
fast if you use Easel.
COLT McANLIS: I highly
recommend
checking out ImpactJS.
I had never written a JavaScript
application before,
and I started with ImpactJS.
And it taught me a lot about the
language, and about how to
manipulate the language and
create object inheritance.
And plus it's got a built-in
level editor inside of it, so
I highly recommend
starting there.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I'm going
to say skip JS and
head straight to Dart.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, look at you.
Are there good--
COLT McANLIS: You've got a
free application, right?
WOLFF DOBSON: Are there tools?
Are there game-making tools?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: There's no
game-making tools yet.
But there's quite a few
libraries, a few of which I've
written, and there's some other
people who are really
interested in Dart for games,
and there's a bit of a
community going.
There's a Dart gamedev list that
you can-- or Google Group
discussion list that
you can join.
COLT McANLIS: Dart's really
exciting for games.
It has some really cool stuff.
WOLFF DOBSON: One of the things
that's great about
programming in Flash is that
you have object types, and
things like this.
COLT McANLIS: Object
inheritance.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: A type
system, imagine.
WOLFF DOBSON: And strongly,
or optionally
strongly typed functions.
COLT McANLIS: I love
the concept of
optionally strongly typed.
Kinda forget about it.
WOLFF DOBSON: Optionally
strong.
It's like theoretically Flash.
TODD KERPELMAN: As not just a
theoretical Flash developer,
as a former Flash developer,
I really like Dart.
I was like, this feels
very comfortable.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I was looking at
a comparison of Dart syntax
to ActionScript, which--
I know nothing about
ActionScript, but I was kind
of like, after looking at side
by side for all of the
language construct, I'm like,
ah, I know ActionScript.
I've got it.
TODD KERPELMAN: I feel like Dart
is kind of the best parts
of both languages.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: There's parts
of many languages, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: There are some
beautifully crazy things you
can do in JavaScript that you
can't do in ActionScript, but.
COLT McANLIS: So I want to
say this real quick, too.
The funny thing is we're all
talking about language here,
and the thing I was trying to
get at at the beginning is
that we should do everything
we can to try to make sure
that language isn't a barrier.
And so if you're one of the
developers out there who also
feel this way, I highly
recommend checking out a new
language called Haxe, H A X E.
The interesting thing about Haxe
is it's sort of designed
as this meta-level language,
that you program in it and it
actually creates output code
that is JavaScript or C++ or
ActionScript or Dart.
The really interesting thing
is, when you talk about
investment over time as a
developer, as a programmer you
care about how you're building
your libraries.
And if you develop it with
Haxe, you're kind of
future-proofing how you're
moving forward, because at
bare minimum you could do a
source-to-source translation
from Haxe to C++ and then move
the direction you need to.
Again, not perfect, but--
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm still going to
harp on debugging, though.
Is it easy to debug Haxe?
COLT McANLIS: So I make no
statements about that.
Just as an option that they
do have support with Flash
developed, and it is out there,
and it is open-source,
and it is free.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I mean, most
debuggers have some concept of
a source map.
Chrome's debugger has it.
GDB, if you emit the correct
DWARF data into your ELF, will
be able to correctly--
WOLFF DOBSON: What are you
emitting into an elf?
COLT McANLIS: That's the topic
of our next show, Emitting
Dwarfs into Elves.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, sadly,
I know what
you're talking about.
I spent a long time
managing my ELF.
COLT McANLIS: Did we have
another question on
[INAUDIBLE]?
WOLFF DOBSON: No,
one last thing.
3JS, if you're looking for a
retained-mode 3D option, 3JS
is pretty cool.
Is there something more--
sort of has a bigger
pipeline than 3JS?
Like, 3JS is great, because it
is this retained-mode thing.
But does, like--
from Maya to something
to something
to rendering framework?
COLT McANLIS: Not that I've
really found, besides the
Flash route.
A lot of people really haven't
embraced 3D on the Web.
I think 3JS is really the
only example of it.
And again, Web developers
typically don't approach
things from the concept of "it's
just data." Traditional
game developers, console game
developers, PC game
developers, they just view it as
a bunch of bytes that they
transform and they
move around.
And so the pipeline is sort
of secondary to them.
The data gets into memory.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, but if
you're really making big
games, you need to get
all the data from--
somebody makes Maya, there's a
pipeline, it gets checked in,
it gets versioned in your
source control--
JOHN McCUTCHAN: My favorite
answer to this question is
this library called Assimp.
The asset importer library.
And this will take--
TODD KERPELMAN: They
need a better name.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: It's
an awesome name.
It's such a good library, too.
It will take any model format,
including animation, and load
it into well-defined,
well-structured C data
structures.
And I used this library to
generate all of the assets for
both of my engines, and I just
have a different exporter.
But the nice thing is it will
load anything that you throw
at it, and then you can
just extract the
vertices and the indices.
And it'll do post-processing,
where it'll clean up the mesh
or regenerate normals,
generate tangents.
COLT McANLIS: So if you're
looking to do 3D on the Web,
definitely check out Assimp.
Definitely look at 3JS.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: It's not an
off-the-shelf solution, but
it'll allow you to write
an exporter.
COLT McANLIS: You know what,
that-- most of game
development is smoke, mirrors,
duct tape and bubble gum, so--
JOHN McCUTCHAN: So true.
COLT McANLIS: --so that's
completely fine.
WOLFF DOBSON: Also, Mr.doob,
he's the, uh.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: He wrote 3JS.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
he wrote 3JS.
And he's on Google+,
you can follow him.
MALE SPEAKER: Speaking of
Google+, a question for you,
Wolff, from the crowd.
This is from typebox76.
He says, what do you think of
the integration of Google
apps, including Google+, into
multiplayer browser games to
include player interaction.
COLT McANLIS: I'm interested
in this myself.
MALE SPEAKER: Or MMORTS.
WOLFF DOBSON: MMORTS.
COLT McANLIS: Whoa,
whoa, wait.
First off, MMORTS, you're
swingin' big, playa.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, that
is a big question.
Obviously I'm a big
fan of Hangouts.
TODD KERPELMAN: You don't say.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, it's true.
It's true.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Hangouts?
I've never heard of them.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
they're neat, you
should try them sometime.
COLT McANLIS: Tell me more.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Now?
COLT McANLIS: If I call now,
do I also get the blender?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, blender is
a different, that's a 3D--
COLT McANLIS: Yes, that is in
the 3D modeling package.
Also free and open-source.
WOLFF DOBSON: There's
a lot-- that's
an interesting question.
It's something that
I'm interested in.
I know with Google+, obviously,
one of the things
that seems small, but it's kind
of big, is that you can
actually use sign-in with Google
to authenticate people,
which means that you aren't
inventing another login form
for your game site,
which is awesome.
Let me see here, what
else can you do?
Google+ in particular.
Hangouts, obviously you can
embed your entire game inside
Hangouts, assuming that it runs
in a Web page someplace.
Which means that everyone
can see it.
Even if you're not running the
game inside a Hangout, you can
actually screenshare from
Hangouts to share your window,
your browser window or whatever,
and actually show
like, look, this is what
I'm seeing right now.
There's some lag there, but
it's still a great way.
In fact, when we played
Warlight in Hangouts,
sometimes is people were having
trouble understanding
the game, I'd just screenshare
my map and be like, see, what
I'm doing is I'm clicking here
and I'm attacking these guys,
and I have these guys here.
It's actually an amazing tool,
and if you think back to the
conversations that you used to
have with people, like when
you were playing Age of Empires
or StarCraft 2, and
you were like, look what
I see, look what I see!
And you can't, because you're
separated by 200 miles, and
you're trying to, like,
"No, over to the--
no, next to the thing!"
There was actually, when I was
playing a long time ago, when
I worked at Southern Graphics
and Doom came out, I remember
sitting back-to-back with
somebody and we were playing
co-op Doom.
I was like hey, you gotta
come look at the map.
And he was like OK, and there
was this long pause.
"Dude, look at the map."
And he's like, what?
I'm looking at the map on my
screen, and I take the map
down, and I see his character
running around me.
And he's like, so is there a
key I press, or something?
And I reach to his chair
and pull it around,
and he's like, oh!
I didn't think of that.
But with Hangouts, you
can actually do it.
You can actually do this Share
moment, and I think that's
very interesting.
TODD KERPELMAN: You
know what I want?
When I start a raid in an MMO,
I want that to post to my
guild people's circle, post
something in my stream that
says, Todd is in a raid.
Why don't you join him?
COLT McANLIS: Click the
link, go to game.
WOLFF DOBSON: If you were in a
Hangout, you can certainly
name your Hangout
Raid Hangout.
And then it will appear in your
stream as "Raid Hangout.
You better join me." And then
you can turn on your
screenshare.
I've actually never tried
screensharing a raid.
That would be--
I'm not sure how that would
work, or if that would work.
Somebody try that and
get back to me.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Homework
for the audience.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'll start a
10-person raid, do it in a
Hangout, see what happens.
COLT McANLIS: Booyeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: Can
you [INAUDIBLE]?
All right.
Do we have time?
We got time.
We got time for one
more question.
And we're going to
stop our-- reset.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: What about
what we're playing?
TODD KERPELMAN: All right,
that's good.
That will be a good
last question.
And we don't even need the timer
for that, because that's
always fun.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Jimmy will
just cut us off.
TODD KERPELMAN: He'll do the
fadeout music, or whatever.
We'll save these other questions
for next time.
John, what are you playing?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: FTL, Faster Than
Light, which is awesome
roguelike-like, as the creators
like to put it.
So it's somewhat, I guess, like
Firefly, where you are a
random gang of criminals
on a ship, and--
WOLFF DOBSON: So it's
like my real life.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it's a typical day.
It starts off and it says,
you're carrying some really
important documents and the
rebels are after you.
And you have to leap, using your
FTL engine, from planet
to planet, from left to
right on this map.
And every time you leap, some
text-based adventure happens,
where it says, OK, you've--
one time I met a cult, and
it's like, do you want
to look into the Eye?
And I'm like, sure.
And then boom, one of my
characters is gone.
Just disappears,
and that's it.
And then you leap to the next
planet and there's a rebel
ship there and you have
to fight them.
And that's when it becomes
almost exactly like an episode
of Star Trek The Next
Generation, because you're
managing your crew by clicking
on them and telling them like,
hey, you, go to the
engine room and
you repair the engine.
You, go to the shields place
and you repair the shields.
You, stay here.
And you start charging up your
weapons, bringing your shields
up, and you have to manage your
power levels and reroute
power to the subsystem that
needs it the most.
And you're taking out the
enemies, and you can even
eventually buy a teleporter
where you could teleport from
your ship to the enemy ship and
then fight hand to hand.
But you have to be careful not
to blow up the enemy ship
while your guys are on it,
because death actually matters
in this game.
TODD KERPELMAN: No
quick saves?
WOLFF DOBSON: Star
Trek 3, here.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: There's
no saves.
WOLFF DOBSON: What is the
computer's voice saying?
Three, two, get off it,
get off the ship.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: It's
a lot of fun.
TODD KERPELMAN: So now wasn't
this a-- am I correct in that
this was a Kickstarter
project originally?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: I think
it was, actually.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, if I recall
correctly, they were
building it for a while and then
they Kickstarted it to
get to the end of it.
COLT McANLIS: Where do
you get the game now?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: ftlgame.com,
I guess.
COLT McANLIS: Is it on Steam?
JOHN McCUTCHAN: It's on Steam,
and you can Google it.
You'll find it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Google
it, huh?
WOLFF DOBSON: What
is this thing?
COLT McANLIS: I'm playing
a great game
called Arcane Legends.
The guys over at Spacetime
Studios actually hooked me up
with a secret code that allowed
me to get a preview of
the game, and I've been
playing it all week.
And it's fantastic.
It's a great MMO that runs on
your phone as well as in the
browser, running with
Native Client.
So it's really cool to be able
to actually pick up my phone
to play the game and then sit at
my desk and play the game,
too, and be able to play against
the guy next to me
who's on his device.
So really cool.
They got a great visual
art look, great new
dynamic with the game.
The monetization really feels
paced instead of-- like, most
micro-transaction stuff you feel
like things are removed
from you that keep you from
having a good time.
No, this game's got it right.
WOLFF DOBSON: All that's removed
from you in this game
is your money, is that
what you're saying?
COLT McANLIS: Yeah,
pretty much.
I'm a super big fan
of this game.
I think it's fantastic.
I cannot wait for
it to launch.
So Spacetime Studios, you
guys gotta hit that.
TODD KERPELMAN: I
saw the trailer.
Cute puppy.
COLT McANLIS: Yeah.
Yeah, the pet mechanic is
really cool, actually.
It kind of walks that line
between Torchlight and a pet
for, like, an MMO.
So mad loot drops as you're
playing the game, and your pet
will run around and pick
it up for you.
But it also doubles as a tank,
or it'll actually fight with
you, but won't split your EXP,
which is really cool.
So it's kind of nice.
You have this really interesting
Tamagotchi
dynamic with it.
You've got to keep it happy and
feed it, but then it also
levels and you can
buy stuff for it.
Really, really nice.
They found the middle
of the road.
Nothing feels too extreme.
It feels like a really
good, clean game.
I'm excited.
I can't wait for it to ship.
TODD KERPELMAN: I was going to
say, if I want to play it now,
is there anything I can do?
COLT McANLIS: You have to email
me, and I'll email the
guys over at Spacetime.
TODD KERPELMAN: Our
audience too?
Should we tell everyone
to email Colt?
COLT McANLIS: I think you should
email Spacetime Studios
and say how excited you are
about the game, and maybe
they'll put you on the beta.
Don't hold me to that.
But yeah, it's a great game.
TODD KERPELMAN: I have had very
little time to play games
the last couple weeks.
I've got my family in town now,
and apparently I can't
ignore them and go off into
the office and play games.
So a little bit of Skyrim,
because that's going to be my
answer for the next year
until I complete it.
But that's been it.
I'm hoping to get back into some
more gaming in the next
couple weeks.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm
the same way.
I've been cranking on stuff, so
I haven't had much chance
to play things.
Still playing SteamBirds.
I got hooked on that, and
now I'm hooked on
getting all the stars.
Because the thing with
SteamBirds is it's like, you
go in and you're like, oh, I got
the bad guys, that's fine.
And it's like, "No stars.
Keep your planes healthier."
And you're like, OK.
Then you go back and then
you're like ohh,
I almost got it!
OK, I understand now.
And I began seeing how the game
fit together and I was
like oh, actually this
is very clever.
I got hooked on it.
But honestly, not much gaming.
Too much building.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: What
is that on?
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm playing
it on my Nexus 7.
You can get it on Android.
I think you can look
for it on the Web.
But honestly, the Nexus 7
experience has been-- again, I
go and I get a sandwich and
I'm sitting in the cafe
dripping barbecue sauce
on my Nexus 7.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: Barbecue
sauce-proof.
You can actually put it in 100
meters of barbecue sauce.
COLT McANLIS: True.
We tried it.
JOHN McCUTCHAN: And
it still works.
COLT McANLIS: We'll have
the video next episode.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, the Nexus 7
has been a really fun gaming
device for me.
I see you're checking out
SteamBirds there.
TODD KERPELMAN: I was.
I was like, let me see what
it's available on.
So I think you and I clearly
need to play more games.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm going to play
some games this weekend,
and I will get back to you.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's sort of
embarrassing that we're in the
Google Games Chat, and--
COLT McANLIS: Well, we'll
shift, we'll shift.
You guys have been working, so
you'll play games for the next
two weeks and we'll
actually do work.
And then shift again.
It's just the ebb and flow
of the universe.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's
like job-sharing.
COLT McANLIS: We're outsourcing
the gameplay.
TODD KERPELMAN: Put that on
my goals for the quarter.
Play more games.
All right.
Well, I think that is it.
We're just about out of time.
We'd like to thank everybody
for joining
us and asking questions.
COLT McANLIS: We love
having questions.
TODD KERPELMAN: That was nice.
It was like we had a little
conversation with you.
COLT McANLIS: Big round
of applause for Jimmy.
Everybody give it
up for Jimmy.
And is Jimmy going
to fade us out?
All right, Jimmy's going
to fade us out.
Bye, everybody!
[MUSIC PLAYING]